in the cbs prime time drama all rise the
main character is a black woman who
serves as a judge in a california
courtroom
it is not a common sight including right
here in nevada
tonight orco mana introduces us to two
local african-american judges
who talk about their unique experiences
behind the bench and how they're
encouraging the next generation
the african-american female perspective
was definitely missing before me
a vital viewpoint in nevada's legal
landscape
judge tierra jones is the first black
woman to be appointed to the district
court bench in the entire state
that happened back in 2017. i'm just so
honored to be a part of you know
starting that trend
jones tells me her diversity is a
driving force in her decision making
especially in life-changing criminal
cases
this as african-americans continue to be
disproportionately incarcerated
you understand that they may have faced
some disadvantages starting out
just because of the color of their skin
and it's something that it definitely
makes you think about because it's an
experience that you have had
jones previously worked as a public
defender and as a prosecutor
she says those career choices which
allowed her to see both sides of the
system
help keep her objective it's very very
important for you to be the neutral man
you to be the neutral magistrate because
that is your job and that's what you are
here to do
african americans only make up a handful
of judges in nevada courtrooms judge
timothy williams was appointed nearly 15
years ago to the district court bench
he says he's noticed that over the years
getting more people of color like him
in this field is a slow but steady
process
we want to have a community that
hopefully a bench that will hopefully
reflect the community but just as
important too
you want to have qualified district
court judges that's what you want to
have
and it just takes time part of that
process is paving a path to the future
jones does this through various
mentorship roles it's
become like a personal responsibility of
mine
so that young women and young
african-american women can see
she looks like me and she did this so
there's nothing stopping me
from being able to do this paying it
forward in an effort
to create change orco mana 8 news now